The next childhood disorder we'll discuss is Autism spectrum disorder. Formally
known simply as Autism. Autism Spectrum Disorder or ASD is characterized by
severe language and social impairment in combination with repetitive habits and
inward focused behaviors. Autism behaviors vary on the continuum from severe
disability to high-functioning. For example, children with a high-functioning
type of autism may have social impairment and skills impairment. But they may
also have more advanced speech capability as well as an above-average
intelligence. Hanz Asberger was the first to describe his high functioning type
of autism and it was since termed Asberger's Syndrome. However, under the
current DSM, Asberger Syndrome is no longer under it's own diagnostic criteria.